[Music]
Devon is next in Houston Texas
I Devon how are you hi Dave I'm great
how are you better than I deserve how
can I help so I have a question about a
car lease my husband and I make about
90,000 a year gross we have no debt no
children we live well below our means
our total absolute necessity costs every
month is right around 2000 we bring home
around 6,000 and my husband wants to
lease a cheap car something like a
Hyundai Elantra or something like that
and I want to know if I should say yes
to it yeah well because we've always
bought cars that were about 10 years old
paid about $5,000 cash and they've
always given us problems the one I have
now is about to lose its transmission do
you have it he's just tired of that
stress he wants to buy a car he just
wants to buy a new car yeah you don't
have the money to buy the car we could
if we wanted to deplete our savings and
I'm not willing to do that how much is
in your savings right now about 15,000
okay all right no I wouldn't take it
down that's is that your only savings
that would be your emergency phone and
everything
no our emergency fund is separate how
much we have about three months worth of
expenses in the Immersion why would you
spend the other 15,000 on the car if
your transmissions are going out on a
car I guess because I have a really
unhealthy relationship with money I grew
up very very poor I've never really will
income why would you want payments then
I I don't know the answer to this
question he really wants to lease a car
and let me just let me start let's
collect this another way okay leasing a
car is financially stupid okay it's the
most expensive way to operate an
automobile according to Consumer Reports
Smart Money Magazine and my calculator
it is the most profitable way
a a car dealership can sell you a car
they make more money on the contract of
the lease than they actually do spread
of profit on the car plus you're buying
a new automobile which is going down in
value like a rock now I don't want you
to go buy a $5,000 junker anymore I get
that you're tired of those I get that
you make $90,000 but I would go buy a
$15,000 really really nice one or
two-year old car and get over yourself
on you're worried about your childhood
or whatever you make $90,000 a year you
don't have any payments you've been very
responsible but no I would not leasing a
car is just a it's financing a car at
15% interest a new car a new car that
goes down in value faster than anything
else see you take that take a $20,000
car twenty twenty-five thousand our car
okay
that car is gonna be worth ten thousand
dollars in 48 months that's straight-up
stupid unless you unless you're worth
over a million dollars you should not
buy a brand-new car under any
circumstances but you should never lease
a car under any circumstances at all
because all it is is financing the car
you're just borrowing the money you know
you guys are two-year-old vehicle it's
fine that's a good purchase
the typical millionaire until they
become a millionaire or greater drives a
two-year-old or older car that no one
knows they're a millionaire and they pay
cash for them most of the loss of the
value occurs in the first one to two
years let me think about the worst car
accidents happen on the showroom floor
as soon as you drive it off the curb it
has dropped in value right right by the
time you get it home I mean we all know
this it's kind of common sense but
what's happened here is is you guys have
saved up the money you're clutching the
fifteen thousand with both hands until
your knuckles are white and he and he's
tired of messing with these dadgum
half-butt breaking down cars y'all have
been driving and you make $90,000 a year
so he's got a right to be disgusted with
that part of it but his reaction due to
his disgust is taking him into the land
of stupid is that logical you see what
I'm saying here yes so it's not a stupid
man but he's getting ready to a very
stupid thing out of frustration so yeah
and I was just hoping I could let him do
something stupid as a way to make him
happy but never let someone hurt
themselves or you as a way to make them
happy
that's just enabling that's codependent
as it can be no look go look up that
exact car what do you say a Hyundai
Elantra or Sonata those are great cars
by the way they're high-quality they're
the all the reports on them of that
they're you know they're right up there
with like a good Honda I mean a koridai
they stay run run run run run run run I
mean they they do really well but go buy
go look at what a two-year-old one is
versus a brand-new one with you know
fifteen twenty thirty thousand miles on
it okay no miles let's get something
real low mile you might find some for
ten thousand miles on it and and look at
its pink in half I mean I mean I did
look and it seemed like it was only
somewhere between three and six thousand
dollar difference from yeah you're
looking at dealer Lots right yeah see
they're trying to sell new cars don't
got the used car prices high jump on the
line do a little research on just used
cars straight up buying a used car in
your area you'll find you'll find these
depreciations would be very very heavy
so anyway what would I do if I were in
your shoes all the data points tell us
that the millionaire's buy used cars
until they're millionaires and they pay
cash for them avoid a car fleece at all
possible in all possible scenarios it's
a really I mean when you put the thing
in a calculator and you know how to run
the calculator
it'll make you throw up it's horrible